peut-être bon sens le csb oui bonsoir
mais subissent une grosse annonce une
grosse décision pour votre gouvernement
pourquoi est-ce que vous la prenez
maintenant pour un pour un ensemble de
raisons écouter on avait dit depuis un
certain tac le masque était recommandé
fortement
il y avait les faits du déconfinement
parce que vous savez lorsqu'on était
confiné l'enjeu du 2 m il était pas là
on a dit quand on commençait dès confiné
qu'il fallait s'assurer qu'on respecte
deux mètres et plus on donne des
occasions aux gens de se déplacer
l'écran du transport collectif à néant
maintenant lorsque les gens ne peuvent
pas toujours respecté le domaine mais il
faut rajouter des mesures de protection
sont complémentaires
alors c'est évident que l'on a vu
arriver quelques codes rehaussement de
leucose journalier du quotidien où on a
vu certaines contagion qu'on appelle
communautaire avec le début de du congé
de la construction qui commence pour le
prochain week-end grèce la sangle de ces
décisions là nous fait passer d'un mode
de recommandations un monde oublié alors
qu'on se comprenne bien c'est quand vous
parlez des commerces et restaurants des
bars restaurants et bars bien entendu
pour consommer va falloir enlever son
masque
mais c'est pour les déplacements à
l'intérieur des locaux vous voulez que
les gens partent porte le match tout à
fait tout à fait on l'a bien vu c'est
sûr on a bien vu les restaurants ça
votre très bien pour ça les gens
lorsqu'ils sont assis parce qu'ils sont
assis c'est facile de rester de
respecter la règle de distanciation
mais quand on se lève dans un restaurant
pour vale peu importe où on a besoin
d'aller ou pour sortir mais à ce moment
là on promet son mas mayhem cet exemple
des restaurants nous nous amène à avoir
été encore plus insistants pour les bas
au cours des 10 beaucoup de gens nous
ont écrit depuis votre annonce à 13h
aujourd'hui un exemple est-ce que la
visière peut remplacer
des gens nous signale d'ailleurs vous
savez dans certains restaurants ou dans
ses fans dont certains vers les employés
ne porte qu'une visière il ne porte pas
de masque
j'aimerais vous entendre là dessus non
nous ont dit clairement que la visière
pour les déplacements ne peut pas
remplacer le mas il faut bien s'entendre
que encore une fois c'est pas juste pour
se protéger nous la viseur c'est plus
pour protéger -sous la personne qui
qu'il apporte
mais le masquer et particulièrement pour
protéger les gens qu'on va rencontrer
dans le corps où il y aurait soit là
symptomatique ou quelqu'un qui est
contagieux il faut s'assurer d'avoir la
maison c'est vrai pour le client et
c'est vrai pour le travailleur à
l'intérieur du commerce
tout à fait on est conscient que c'est
que c'est pas facile surtout que c'est
l'été au besoin de se faire de dessin
mais l'enjeu est tellement important ni
québécois ont travaillé tellement fort
pour en arriver à au succès connu à
l'intérieur de deux des derniers mois
que je pense qu'il faut pour preuve
aucun bon parlons de dufer donc ça mais
sur les épaules des commerçants
maintenant vous avez déjà vu les
réactions depuis l'annoncé il est écouté
comment ça se fait que ça va reposer sur
nos épaules pourquoi est-ce que c'est
nous commerçants qui risquent des
amendes qui vont de 400 à 6000 $ qu'est
ce qu'on fait avec un client
récalcitrant qui rend dans notre
établissement et qui refuse de porter un
masque on peut quand même pas faire
pression jusqu'à ce qu'ils aient une
altercation
non effectivement écoutez si vous me
demandiez où je pense que ça va aboutir
c'est que des gens vont tellement bien
réagir qu'on n'aura pas besoin de mettre
des amendes aux individus pas plus qu'on
veut en donner vos commerces mais comme
si le commerçant à très court terme je
parle d'années les prochains jours
prochaines semaines c'est eux qui
contrôlent d'entrée de leur commerce
alors nous on a voulu commencer par eux
mais on était très clair le premier
ministre le dit en point de presse me
dit si jamais au cours des prochaines
semaines
on voit que les gens pour aix raison ne
suivent pas la directive dont le déjà
averti qu'on aurait des amendes aussi
pour les individus ça doit être un
travail collectif
bon on commence par ceux qui contrôlent
une entrée dans le coma vous avez dit
quelque chose aujourd'hui qui a étonné
pendant le point de presse et concernant
le transport en commun où on entendait
finalement que même les chauffeurs
d'autobus vont devoir se faire la police
du masque c'est à dire interdire l'accès
à leurs moyens de transport à leur
autobus une personne qui refuserait de
porter le masque
vous savez que ça vous ruer dans les
brancards il ya des chauffeurs d'autobus
ce qu'ils disent est hors de question
que je serai seul le chemin sûr on peut
pas faire on peut pas me donner ce
mandat là mais ce qu est ce qu on a dit
au début si vous rappeler c'était de que
c'était la responsabilité des sociétés
de transport les sociétés de transport
vont travailler avec leurs employés
parce que je leur dit celui qui est
l'intervenant sur place c'est pas la stm
c'est le chauffeur de toulouse moi je
vous dis je vous donne à partir de
comparaison comment depuis quelques
jours on a noté tout le monde a noté que
beaucoup plus de gens qui portent le
masque depuis quelque temps parce qu'une
pression sociale des gens sont encore
alors quand vous serez une seule où
quelques personnes uniques qui seront
dans un autobus je pense que la pression
sera pas uniquement sur le chauffeur
mais il va être sur un individu qui ne
porteront pas le masque ils sont le but
commun des québécois ont collaboré
jusqu'à maintenant je pense qu'on sable
vous savez que des gens qui se trouvent
sur des raisons pour pas emporter fait
trop chaud aux os malaire espérait il
fonde la sinon ce soir de maladie on a
entendu des vies cela est longue la
liste mais ont besoin d'un point de
presse avec monsieur et madame monsieur
à vous dire qu'ils disent pas parce
qu'on fait un petit peu d'asthme qu'on
se soustraient l'obligation de porter un
masque vais vous aller un peu plus loin
sur cette lancée là mais je vais laisser
l'expert un expert a dit chronicles mais
ce qu'on veut dire c'est qu'on se fie à
la bonne foi des gens je veux dire c'est
évident que quelqu'un qui arrive aux
guichets du métro
on va laisser beaucoup de jugement à ce
qu'ils ont à prendre la décision mais
s'il ya des gens qui nous disent on veut
confiant cependant la caisse on n'est
pas là on a vu déjà très raisonnable de
bonne foi bon des derniers mois je pense
pas qu'on est là mais à mon ami
on va voir comment les choses évoluent
mais je pense pour combler vous me
parlez des gens de bonne foi mais il y
aussi ceux qui pour une question de
principe refuse catégoriquement vous
savez tous ces gens là qui brandissent
la liberté individuelle ici l'entrée de
mme aubry mais qui sont surprenamment
très visible je voudrais dans les
réseaux sociaux il donne l'impression
d'être non je sais pas s'ils sont
vraiment nombreux me donne une
impression dans les réseaux sociaux
qu'est ce que vous faites avec ces gens
là qui s'obstine comme ça écoutez moi je
pense qu'on doit leur refuser l'accès
est très très clair niang est un choix
appelé liberté individuelle puis le bien
être collectif de tout le monde et je
crois lorsqu on comprend qu'ils ont une
vue d'un des derniers mois et dernières
semaines on a vu aux états unis quand
les libertés prennent le dessus
c'est toute la société qui en payent le
et pour ça nous allons être très
stressée des individus après avoir donné
le temps nécessaire de passer à cette
étape là qui ne veulent pas respecter
les règles mais qu ils seront interdits
soit le transport collectif où ils
auront des amendes importantes au niveau
des lieux publics
ça va être très clair c'est super merci
beaucoup pour les précisions merci pour
l'entrevue fait plaisir à bientôt
merci